ist ja eigentlich schon fast ein
bisschen verantwortungslos so was für
seine kinder zu kaufen ja drei kilogramm
da muss man schon fünflinge haben oder
halb fünf kleinkinder aber für euch
selber könnt euch 35 euro hey was geht
ab jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt
gut ich fühle mich also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen hätte ich mit 56 jahren
fünf adventskalender gehabt ich werde
der glücklichste mensch der welt gewesen
er ich habe es ja in meinem letzten
amazon video schon angekündigt es geht
heute um adventskalender ich weiß wir
haben gerade mal mitte oktober
trotzdem habe ich mir gedacht bist du
dich aber erst noch nicht war aber zum
unterwegs hat ein paar coole sachen
bestellt und da wurden wir auch schon
voll viele adventskalender angezeigt und
ich habe gedacht er com bestellt sein
5achs die aus test ist die und hast dann
auch gleichzeitig fünf würde ich selber
den auf jeden fall alle megacool
ausbauen werde hier ist echt schwer alle
links zu den kalendern sind in der video
beschreibung das heißt wenn ihr sagt hey
den hätte ich auch gerne einfach die
video besteht man auch mal auf den link
klicken dann kommen wir direkt bei
amazon werden halt wirklich fünf
kalender und diese mal schnell im
schnelldurchlauf leute ganz wichtig noch
bevor es losgeht habe ich nur eine frage
ich und zwar habe ich weiß natürlich
nicht ob es klappt zeitlicher wie kam
dieses jahr die idee einen eigenen
adventskalender zu machen also sohn alex
wie adventskalender und ich wollte
einfach jetzt mal in diesem video fragen
weil es der ehemann events kalender geht
ob er darauf lust hätte das soll jetzt
kein besonders großes ding sein ist aber
einfach ein cooler lustiger
adventskalender seien mit ein paar
lustigen sachen drin falls ihr sagt
coole idee macht das doch mal schreibt
auf jeden fall gern mal einfach hashtag
adventskalender in die kommentare
dann sehe ich das ja und dann gebe ich
mir mal mehr dass wir das vielleicht
dieses jahr noch hinkriegen weil sie es
nicht klappt natürlich dann als nächstes
jahr aber ich hätte auf jeden fall lust
drauf man es hätte das tier dazu sagt
und jetzt geht's los
der gummi bärige adventskalender nummer
zwei sieht auch mehr geld aus einer
bands kalender von pick up die machen
sehr leckere süßigkeiten wie ich finde
nummer drei ich habe keine
was hier genau drin ist mit 24 lustigen
images bin ich endlich mal gespannt ob
er sich hierbei um schokolade oder was
auch immer handelt
hier haben wir einen kalender von fedora
ich glaube das ist ein beauty kalender
mit beauty produkten definitiv nein zum
schluss meinen geheimfavoriten und zwar
eins marty adventskalender in einem
wirklich geilen design eine burg oder
dem burgturm ich würde sagen dann bietet
es sich auch gleich an mit denen hier
anzufangen leider durch den transport
hier die fünf beschädigt deswegen würde
ich sagen wir machen die auch einfach
mal direkt auf haben hier habe ich mir
auch schon so gedacht dass marty
verpackung glaube dass wir in liebe habe
ich auf jeden fall bei aufmärschen ist
eigentlich alles klar
es ist eigentlich recht gut gemacht hier
oben kann man direkt dann die leere
verpackung darauf knallen und ja ich
würde sagen wir machen einfach mal die
24 jahren ich weiß was macht man
eigentlich nicht aber es hing test und
hier haben wir den smart winterspaß
hätte ich so noch gar nicht zu sagen
probieren wir mal kurz ja schon ewig
keine schokolade mehr gegessen
hi leute ich nehme im nachhinein noch
kurz hier ja einmal so dieses produkt an
sich auf amazon habe ich einen letzten
videos auf mehr gemacht wir fangen an
mit dem smarties kalender hat eigentlich
eine ganz gute bewertung kostet 13 euro
nicht okay den adventskalender besonders
für kinder
also genau das richtige für mich
gestaltung ist sehr schön und
süßigkeiten dem gut verteilt da muss ich
sagen das fand ich auch also wir hatten
mir sehr gut gefallen
das war der erste kalender ich würde
sagen machen weiter mit dem zweiten
nehmen wir einfach mal diesen smiley
kalender von lindt habe ich eben gar
nicht gesehen also
also dem titel schiller ist
wahrscheinlich amazon adventskalender
oder adventskalender von amazon keine
ahnung die kann man sicherlich auch
nirgendwo anders kaufen
ich habe die allerdings noch mehr
gesehen außer auf amazon deswegen hier
das wären titel top der weg irgendwie
als wir das schnell auseinander brechen
ich bin jetzt werde ich mal gespannt was
hier drin ist wir machen einfach mal
zusammen die einst auch hier oben
okay es ist auch schokolade
ja wir haben hier vermutlich oder ich
hoffe mal hier ist jetzt schokolade
darunter auch wirklich sehr sehr lecker
ich gehe mal davon aus dass überall hört
einer schokolade drin ist deswegen mache
ich jetzt nichts weiteres auf was
ebenfalls sehr wichtig finde ist dass
die lebensmittel hier drin sind nicht
nach papier oder nach karton schmecken
ist ja auch zu einfach wenn das ding ja
schon zwei monate liegt oder sowie
springen jetzt wirklich noch gut also
auch dies im kalender dem man sich auf
jeden fall können kann als nächstes
haben geht in hello adventskalender mini
energy soll das denkmal ist einfach
nicht auch echt cool kostet sogar nur 9
euro hat auch eine ähnliche bewertung
wieder eben
und wer glaube ich so wenn man jetzt
nicht zu viel geld ausgeben möchte mein
favorit als nächstes würde ich sagen
kommen wir zum beauty kalender glaube
ich ach nee eigentlich wollte ich einen
duty kalender bestellen
wir haben hier jetzt ich glaube wir sind
pralinen drin die frage ist jetzt
natürlich mit alkohol oder ohne ich habe
keine ahnung also ausgepackt sieht das
so aus ich würde hier sagen wir machen
mal die kommen die 23 auf haben wir
haben eine praline
da ist auf jeden fall drin also für alle
116 nachfolger von malakka ist lustig
ist eher hinten steht darauf bis wann
das heißt fünfzehnter siebter 2009 10
die frage ist wer hat es denn bis dahin
nicht längst leer gegessen oder wer
kauft sich das dann auch naja muss
wahrscheinlich rutschen einfach hier ein
cooler kalender
wie die palmen kauft euch den ansonsten
ganz klar hierfür vielleicht die etwas
älteren unter euch ja die gibt es ja
auch ich bin immer verwundert was mich
für leute manchmal ansprechen auf der
straße den finde ich wirklich sehr sehr
preiswert 8 eur 71 alles voll mit
pralinen also da kann man sich wirklich
nicht beschweren
er hat irgendwie gar keine bewertung
deswegen machen wir das mal kurz genau
das richtige
ich wollte halt kalender haben wir auch
irgendwie ja keine lebensmittel drin
sondern irgendwas anderes wahrscheinlich
werden wir das heute eher nicht haben
ich gehe davon aus dass bei diesem
kalender eigentlich auch noch was zum
essen drin ist wie wollen anscheinend
alle dass ich werde ich finde es
eigentlich immer echt schade wenn hinten
drauf stehen was alles drin ist ja wir
haben hier komplett wir machen einfach
mal die 14 auf und hier haben wir kick
dunkel mit weißer schokolade muss ich
aber eigentlich sogar sagen finde ich
gut ja verschiedene sorten die man sonst
gar nicht unbedingt mal alles probiert
hier vor allem dieses ganz dunkel habe
ich noch nie gegessen für die die gerne
kekse mit schokolade essen weil das auf
jeden fall eine möglichkeit ist es dass
jetzt nicht weil irgendwann reicht's
auch ich muss aber sagen von dem gefällt
werde ich das design am besten also wenn
man denen so an der wand hängen hat ich
glaub ich hängen die alle sodann die
wand und das zeige ich euch dann gleich
mal wie das aussieht er von dem ihr war
ich auch wirklich begeistert finde ich
allerdings ein bisschen teuer hat sogar
fast fünf sterne 13 euro dafür
man muss sagen das design ist wirklich
toll also das hat mir eigentlich so
design technisch am besten gefallen von
allen mal gucken was die leute dazu
schreiben man bekommt was man bestellt
aber auch nicht mehr leben kann ich auch
zustimmen viel verpackungsmüll auf jeden
fall also wenn man sowieso gerne so pick
up markt dann ist es wirklich ein geiles
ding für kinder oder auch für mich leute
und willkommen zu meinem größten
kalender das ding hat glaube ich auf 35
euro kostet von ob es das wert ist das
schauen wir mal
wir haben auf jeden fall drauf stehen
xxl wird mehr als drei kilogramm
gummibärchen also
da bin ich jetzt wirklich mal gespannt
ist ja eigentlich schon fast ein
bisschen verantwortungslos so was für
seine kinder zu kaufen ja drei kilogramm
da muss man schon fünflinge haben oder
als fünf kleinkinder aber für euch
selber könnt euch 35 euro die frage ist
wo sind denn jetzt ab so das muss man
auch machen
oh warte man mir das ist die 23 das
finde ich um ehrlich zu sein nicht ganz
so gut
wir haben hier jetzt warte ja das ist
sie 24 einfach ganz schön zur pakete mit
irgendwelchen gummi mit deswegen ist das
ding auch schwer hätte man meiner
meinung nach eigentlich besser machen
können indem man hier einfach kläppchen
macht aber gut vielleicht hat es
irgendwelche gründe wir machen einfach
mal er kommt weil wir machen die 24 euro
vielleicht ist das ja auch bei jedem
anders keine ahnung ich muss ja eine
packung weingummi bisher also die finde
ich sogar echt geil
vielleicht ein kurzer vergleich hier die
22 vor diesen auch geld also eigentlich
cooler kalender schauen der videos
verlinkt gut ja und hier jetzt noch der
letzte 5 sterne
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen 30 euro für
24 pakete gummibärchen ist okay wenn man
die verpackung dazu rechnet aber
eigentlich kommt man da günstiger weil
weg und das sind halt wirklich 3,4
kilogramm gummibärchen die man dann da
hat ist schon viel jeden tag eine
packung gummibärchen
wer es gerne mag kann es machen aber ja
also den könnte man auf jeden fall
leuten empfehlen die wirklich gerne
gummibärchen essen und vielleicht auch
noch mal was neues entdecken wollen weil
ich habe noch ein paar mehr köpfchen
aufgemacht und es waren wirklich sachen
dabei die kannte ich so noch werden das
waren 5 adventskalender die ich auch bei
amazon gefunden haben die leute unter
euch die vielleicht auch schon ein
bisschen älter sind eigentlich nie so
wirklich anderen
ist keiner denken vielleicht konnte ich
das ein bisschen auffrischung ist ja an
sich doch immer ganz lustig das was mit
dem video lassen doch nach oben da man
zwischenfall hat und ich mache mich
jetzt hier an die leckeren
überraschungen absurden jetzt gestaltet
kurz noch hier unsere wohnung moment
hängen jetzt zwei meiner kalender ja
dieses bild ist leider angeklebt aber
seht ihr finde ich echt cool aus weil
wenn man jedoch die weiteren aufhängt
das mache ich jetzt gleich noch das
macht mir doch bisschen musik kaufen und
einbauen und war es auf weihnachten das
ist das was wir dem video habe ich ja
schon gesagt daumen nach oben wir sehen
uns